man
um who's your dream collaboration like
who's like that one artist
that even no matter how unrealistic it
is like
that that you would you want to work
with
people probably gonna make fun of me but
i say chris brown hey
i feel like chris brown is untouchable
any anything he touched it just turned
into gold
i just had a conversation with you know
who gash he is the singer gashy no
so we had a conversation about how chris
brown in my opinion
is the most talented artist to ever that
i've ever seen
and when i'm talking talent i'm not
talking about i mean he could sing and
he could dance better than everybody but
he could also paint your house
right and like he does murals and
not human i mean he's obviously got his
flaws with all our flaws you know he's
just much more public but god damn if he
don't got more 10 this [ __ ]
could hit a jumper
that's a fact when he did that backflip
on stage and they was comparing him to
michael jackson
and yeah and and fair point he'll
probably take
99 of everybody's wife's
he's chris brown that's a talent you
know got to give it to him
um yeah i'm going to put i think you
working with chris brown has got to
happen in the next 12 months i feel like
absolutely
it's happened i feel like that you could
kind of you could kind of put that in
like like in the atmosphere it's gonna
happen yeah i'm gonna manifest that for
sure
chris brown i'm gonna work with you come
on what about somebody like super
unexpected
soda baby's a nickelback fan which was
[ __ ] weird
um that's the worst band ever
i would say somebody like adele ah shout
out to adele man
yeah i think everything she make is just
big like stadium well her music is like
obviously she just became a meme shout
out to her for representing that's funny
on jamaica day
but no but like her music is like
timeless it's like
it's like [ __ ] that like she's a living
legend for sure
do you think you sing do you think when
someone loses weight like that
does their voice change i don't know
that's a good question
i think i think her voice is the same oh
i mean i don't know i don't think we've
heard skinny adele yet i don't think
she's dropped some [ __ ] since she's
she's been on her fitness shout out to
her though